[Music]
good morning
welcome to sky news breakfast in a major
unveiling of what our future with
coronavirus may look like the government
has announced plans for
covid passports to allow people to
attend sports matches
nightclubs theatres and other events the
system being developed will consider
three factors vaccination a recent
negative test
or natural immunity having tested
positive for the virus in the previous
six months pilots for the certificates
launch in just over a week's time
with a nightclub in liverpool and
football matches at wembley amongst the
first to get the go-ahead
the prime minister has also announced a
traffic light system for international
travel
in a bid to restart foreign holidays our
chief political correspondent john craig
reports
football's coming home
[Applause]
gradually this is how it used to be
fans streaming along wembley way on
their way to an england international
in 2019 now three showpiece domestic
games at wembley
the semi-final and the final of the fa
cup and the carabao
cup final will be among nine vaccine
passport trials
with fans allowed back in the stadium in
april and may
the government says it's developing a
system for covid status certification
the idea is to manage risks where large
numbers of people
are in close proximity not in pubs or
restaurants at this stage
but at sports events and festivals or in
theaters and nightclubs
at this large nightclub in london before
lockdown it could accommodate up to 1400
revellers
but the manager fears vaccine passports
could be another burden
on an industry already on the brink if
they're going to start cutting
capacities if they're going to start
letting less people in
or we're going to slow hues down from
coming into venues you know it's just
going to have an adverse effect it's
just going to you know
delay the inevitable and eventually
venues will run out they'll be strapped
for cash they won't be able to operate
because the the restrictions are just
going to be too too heavy on venues
the cabinet office minister michael gove
says the government is studying a green
pass system used in israel which allows
people who've been vaccinated
recently recovered from covid or have
had a negative test
to congregate in theaters and nightclubs
but the strong opposition to vaccine
passports from many mps
this weekend a cross-party group of 72
mps signed a pledge opposing the scheme
claiming it's divisive and
discriminatory
if the plan does require legislation the
government may try to win over the
rebels
by promising it'll only be temporary
perhaps for no more than a year
besides vaccine passports boris johnson
will tomorrow
also announce new plans for
international travel this summer
travelers will face a traffic light
system
people returning from a green-like
country will not have to self-isolate
but will need to provide a negative test
before departure
and after arrival those returning from
an amber country
must self-isolate at home while anyone
returning from a red-light country
will have to complete quarantine in a
hotel and
bear the cost
summer holidays to europe will depend of
course on vaccination
levels on the continent improving and
infection rates falling
john craig sky news
now political correspondent rob powell
joins me now from westminster rob how is
all of this likely to go down with mps
and
most importantly businesses so i think
jillian there's probably a fair amount
in there that will reassure i think the
fact that
the government has said that travel
transport and shops will not be subject
to this covered passporting scheme
no mention of pubs and restaurants being
involved
for now anyway i think that was one of
the main concerns that mps had that
they'd be checking certificates and
passports to get into
more everyday settings that's not to say
there won't be concerns though
michael gove in the papers today says
that this covered passporting scheme
is all about helping business about
getting places open without social
distancing
to allow them to make more money in the
short term but we've already heard from
the manager of the
liverpool comedy club that's due to have
pretty much the first
pilot of this covert passporting scheme
and he said
he'd signed up to test people on the way
in and the way out and didn't know that
there was anything to do with
vaccination certificates
in this scheme and he's already had
people phone up and try and cancel
because they are uncomfortable with the
idea of having to show they've had the
jab
we know others in hospitality are
worried about the extra staff that may
be needed to do checks like this
i think there will be concern about how
long schemes like this go on for whether
they are going to be
strictly temporary or whether they drift
into something more permanent
um on international travel and this
traffic light scheme that's been
unveiled
i think that framework will be broadly
welcomed by the travel and tourism
industry
it is what they have been calling for
but of course the detail is crucial in
this specifically what countries go into
each
section and what dates the government
will be operating off we know may the
17th is the earliest
date that they've got down for leisure
travel non-essential travel to start
that date still hasn't been confirmed
yet
and i think the industry will be
probably quite frustrated that the
government is still telling people not
to book summer holidays
given that many operators will have
refund schemes cancellation schemes
flexible rebooking policies as well
don't forget as well that this is all
being negotiated and talked about with
the devolved governments in scotland
wales
and northern ireland and we have seen
those administrations go in a different
direction if they're uncomfortable with
what's been proposed here in westminster
rob thank you well let's get the latest
now macovid figures for the uk
3423 new covid19 cases have been
reported
with 10 more deaths that takes the total
number of people who've died within 28
days of testing positive
to 126 826.
the figures also show that 31.4 million
first doses of vaccine have now been
given
police and politicians in northern
ireland have appealed for calm following
a second night of violence around
belfast
petrol bombs were thrown in sandy row
while three cars in newton abbey were
hijacked and set on fire
it comes after eight people were
arrested and 27 police officers were
injured during riots on friday
police and protesters have clashed at
kill the bill protests in london
over the police crime and sentencing
bill 26 people were arrested in the
capital and 10
officers suffered injuries amid a day of
largely peaceful demonstrations across
the country
around a thousand people gathered in
bristol and further events were held
in liverpool manchester and birmingham
former labour leader jeremy corbyn spoke
at the gathering in central london
saying the proposed legislation
is a very dangerous slippery slope to
inhibiting
the right to protest
jordanian authorities have denied
reports that prince hamza jordan's
former crown prince and the half-brother
of king abdullah
have been arrested for attempting a coup
they say he's been told to stop
destabilizing activities that are
targeting jordan's security
following the arrest of at least two
former senior palace officials
u.s rapper dmx is in hospital in new
york following a heart attack
his lawyer confirmed that the musician
whose real name is earl simmons had come
off life support but said he was still
concerned about the star's condition
musicians including missy elliott and
eminem have been wishing him well
online let's return to our top story now
the government announcing plans to
introduce a traffic light system for
international travel
the move will see quarantine measures
dropped for green light destinations
which could provide a boost to the uk
travel industry
joining me now is dan pierce the chief
executive of the travel trade gazette
good morning to you
and what's your view of this traffic
light system is it workable
in your view good morning jillian uh
yeah i think the message from the travel
industry is that it broadly
welcomes uh this announcement although
of course it's not an announcement
yet of a traffic light system
there's been a huge amount of
frustration around all the
speculation that's come sometimes from
the the amounts of government ministers
around whether you can or you can't
travel
this summer i think what the the
industry really
wants and craves at the moment is some
certainty that would enable
consumers to book travel with confidence
and of course for the industry
to get their planning in place for a
summer season
which really doesn't happen overnight
and as we understand it with this
traffic light system
uh those on green it would mean that you
wouldn't have to isolate if
traveling to those countries is that how
you understand it
yeah that's right there'd be a green an
amber
and a red list of the red list is is
already effectively in place
and i'm sure everyone's heard about the
quarantine hotels
of which a number of countries suddenly
i think i think it's about 35
currently if you travel to those
countries you have to go into a
quarantined hotel
on the other hand under the the green
lights with this proposed traffic light
system people will be able to to travel
freely to certain countries however they
will require
a test within 72 tower 72 hours of
departure
and two tests in the days following
their return
but that is a big step forward after a
lot of speculation that there wouldn't
be any international travel at all this
year
how confident are you that that
international travel will resume
on may the 17th
there's an increasing confidence around
the travel industry
and one of the key reasons for that is
the travel industry is now being
fully consulted in the government's
plans
there was a lot of frustration last year
the government announced a
global travel task force in the autumn
of 2020
and yet no member no representative from
the travel industry
sat on that task force and i think there
was you know a bit of a gap in
understanding about what was going on in
the industry
i mean and due to some really great
lobbying work that's gone on across the
industry
there are now many members from travel
senior representatives being included in
consultation
and i think uh all eyes really are on
the the conclusions of the global
travel task force which is due out not
tomorrow
but uh next week um i think around april
the 12th
and yet we do know and we know this from
the prime minister's own mouth that
there are going to be
some aspects of this trails this week
and you've launched this save travel
campaign or what exactly are you calling
for in that what are the elements that
are
vital to ensure that the travel industry
is able to get back on its feet
one of the key aspects here is that the
travel industry has not
had an ounce of sector specific
support since the beginning of the
crisis
now this is an industry that's that's
really had a double whammy you know in
many ways
obviously business has stopped and come
to a halt you know which it did
as it did for most industries last year
but this is also an industry that has
had to
to pay back um nearly all of the
business that it did
in the months preceding the crisis so
it's had it on both sides and
a huge crash cash crunch um in the
industry which has been
absolutely devastating to travel so yeah
ttg launched the safe travel campaign
which raised these issues and parliament
and i really do hope that that's had you
know
an effect and that's one of many reasons
in which travel is now being fully
consulted
uh the government's advice uh president
is still not to book a summer holiday
um what would you say to people who are
undecided as to whether they should book
should they
well i'd say something very clear around
this
and it's easy to mistake uh that advice
booking travel can i actually travel
it's not illegal to book a holiday it's
very legal to book a holiday and the
best advice
to offer anybody watching is to talk to
a travel
professional you know there is an army
of travel agents out there
experts in travel experts just as much
as accountants are experts in finance
lawyers are experts in legal aspects
talk to a travel
professional and they will help you book
that
summer holiday or beyond into 2022
but that holiday that will give you
something to look forward to
as we emerge from the coronal virus
crisis
okay dan pierce chief executive of the
travel trade gazette thank you very much
for speaking to us and for the advice
nicola sturgeon says scotland's
controversial not proven verdict in the
court
should be looked at scotland is the only
part of the uk where juries can return
three verdicts at the end of a trial
guilty not guilty or not proven
rape crisis scotland want the verdict
scrapped amid what the first minister
called
shamefully low conviction rates for rape
and sexual assault
a state of emergency has been declared
in florida following a significant leak
at a wastewater storage pond
containing radioactive material at an
old phosphate mine it's feared the walls
are about to be breached
flooding the area local residents have
been evacuated and a highway has been
closed as a precaution
the duke of cambridge has urged people
to fight climate change and take the
lead from young people who are looking
for solutions
in a video message played at a gala for
u.s based charity conservation
international
prince william said the next decade
would be one of our greatest
ever tests if we do not act decisively
in the next 10 years we will cause
irreversible damage to our planet
this damage will not be felt equally by
everyone it is the most vulnerable
those with the fewest resources and
those who have done the least
to cause climate change who will
continue to be impacted the most
all of us across all sectors of society
and in every corner of the globe
must come together to fundamentally
reset our relationship with nature
the education secretary has said that
investing in the next generation of
teachers is crucial to long-term
recovery
gavin williamson says the single most
important factor in schooling is the
quality of the teacher
his comments come as the general
secretary of the teachers union has
criticized the government's handling of
the pandemic
saying ministers treated teachers with
contempt by not rewarding their efforts
with
a pay rise egypt has held a parade to
celebrate
moving 22 of its mummies from the
egyptian museum
in cairo's tourist square to a new
museum elsewhere in the capital
the mummies 18 kings and four queens
were each transported by road in their
own capsule
filled with nitrogen to provide
protection
[Music]
christians around the world have been
marking easter sunday as the pope
urged people not to lose hope in the
dark months of the pandemic
pope francis said he hoped that people
would rediscover the grace of everyday
life
at a scaled back easter vigil last night
only two
most 200 master faithful were allowed to
attend the service in saint peter's
basilica
catholics in sri lanka have attended
church services to marquis to sunday but
they fulfilled one of the churches in
colombo
which was bombed during attacks on
easter services
two years ago which left 290 people dead
in jerusalem people have gathered to
commemorate easter in person
in sharp contrast to last year thanks to
israel's successful
vaccination campaign although most
palestinians in the west bank
are yet to receive a vaccine
here in the uk the prime minister said
in his easter message that it had been a
very
tough year boris johnson acknowledged
restrictions meant many would once again
be unable to celebrate in the normal way
but said brighter days are to come
starma meanwhile used his easter message
to pay tribute to the christian
community
for supporting others during the
pandemic the labour leader said he was
in awe of their efforts over the last 12
months
and thanked them for their support
now if you're heading to church this
morning be careful to follow
social distancing rules police in south
london were filmed shutting down a good
friday service
and threatening worshipers with arrest
but the church has criticized the
officers saying it believes that all the
rules were being met
and has accused the police of brutally
exceeding their powers
sadia chowdhury reports you are not
allowed to meet inside with this many
people
under law easter service halted by
threats of 200-pound fines
failure to comply with this direction to
leave and go to your home address
ultimately could lead you to be fined
200 pounds
or if you fail to give your details to
being arrested police say those present
were clearly not
socially distanced the worshipers
quietly walked out but as services
resumed today
many said officers had taken a step too
far
precautions were made everyone was
keeping distance everyone had muscle
i obviously felt very offended as
i would say this is the most important
day
of the year for us christians i was so
surprised why that happened and
where is their right the church is
located within the archdiocese of
southwark which today cited national
guidance issued by the catholic bishops
conference of england and wales
and said public worship is permissible
where coveted hygiene procedures are in
place
in a statement the metropolitan police
said officers were called to a report of
crowds of people queuing outside a
church in balum high road
officers attended and found a large
number of people inside the church
some people were not wearing masks and
those present were clearly not
socially distanced as such officers made
the decision
that it was not safe for that particular
service to continue
according to the latest guidance there
are no restrictions on how many people
can gather for communal worship
as long as they can be safely
accommodated i think it
was uh a very shocking thing that they
went in and and stopped the service
it's good that the government take
measures and it's important
because we must help people not to fall
sick
but once it's been proved with evidence
that
religious services do not spread this
virus if they're covered secure
and that the government have allowed
this then the police shouldn't
overstep the mark the church has accused
police of brutally exceeding their
powers
that's strongly disputed by officers who
have the difficult job of enforcing
regulations
sadia chowdhury sky news in southwark
happy easter everybody how will you be
spending yours uh in the sunshine
yes yes sunshine and hopefully those
easter eggs won't melt in it because uh
it will be quite a warm day across
southern areas with lots of dry and
sunny weather but in the north
it will eventually become colder with
some wintry showers
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning there's lots of fine
weather to be had today across
many central southern parts of the uk
island but from the north it is going to
start turning cloudier
with rain spreading south was then
behind that another front comes through
with some wintry outbreaks and very
strong northerly winds bringing through
an arctic
airflow so everywhere by easter monday
is going to feel noticeably colder
it's a chilly start this morning though
in fact from clear skies from most
places overnight therefore it's a sunny
start to the day but it's frosty
there are areas of mist and fog less
cold down towards southern and eastern
parts of england where we've seen more
in the way of cloud and also across the
north and west of england and
wales in fact some patchy light rain and
drizzle across the north of
scotland that will be moving its way
southwards across scotland ahead of it
it will become cloudier this afternoon
across parts of northern ireland the
north of the republic later northwest
england so the sunshine
turning hazy across these parts and
there will be limited amounts of
brightness by the end of the day
and then from the north of scotland
there will be northerly winds developing
becoming quite strong with wintry
showers but for most of ireland england
and wales
sunny and warm
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
good morning you're watching sky news
breakfast the government has set out
plans for covered passports with
pilots due to begin in under two weeks
time a nightclub in liverpool and the fa
cup semi-final at wembley are amongst
the first to get the go-ahead
the prime minister has also announced a
traffic light system for international
travel in a bid to restart foreign
holidays
heading to green light destinations will
not require
quarantine
police and politicians in northern
ireland have appealed for calm
following a second night of violence
around belfast
the trial of derek shovin the police
officer
accused of killing george floyd in
minneapolis
in last year
[Music]
as we're saying the trial of derek
shoving the police officer accused of
killing george floyd
in minneapolis last year is set to
continue next week
powerful witness testimonies have made a
compelling start to a trial
that could define america's future
attorney and
legal analyst anne bremner joins us now
from
seattle good morning to you what have
you made of
proceedings thus far
well it's been quite a week i'm sorry i
was just putting in some earphones um
the prosecutions had a very strong week
they started a course with a dispatcher
that thought that things looked
troubling to her and she actually called
a supervisor called the sergeant
to say that she didn't feel things were
right which she sounds like she'd never
done before and she sounded like
she said i don't want to sound like a
snitch that's what they started with the
week
they had all the civilian witnesses that
were very traumatized by not being able
to help
um george floyd when they tried to and
they tried to intervene at donald
williams who had
martial arts training said this was a
blood choke a choke
basically choking somebody so their
blood wouldn't go through
their neck he knew about this kind of a
um hold that he tried to intervene and
say
that this shouldn't be happening there
was a 17 year old
with her nine-year-old cousin she did
her name was darnella we didn't get a
last name because she was a juvenile at
the time who filmed all of this
and her videos the one that went viral
around the world
of derek chavez
chavez excuse me basically having his
knee on george floyd's neck
and then of course we heard from medics
that said he was essentially dead when
they when they got there
and then at the very end they had a very
strong witness of lieutenant zimmerman
who said that the use of force i was
totally excessive
totally inappropriate and and that was
a very strong opinion coming from
someone that works in homicide and has
been in the forest for 35 years
yeah so that that that strong opinion
saying totally uh unnecessary and the
17 year old that that filmed the entire
incident
uh spoke of the the guilt that that she
felt perhaps not doing more
yeah and then she said that she would
wake up at night you know thinking about
what she could have done i mean it's
something that's really troubled her and
she talked a lot about
you know her own her own family and
about this could be a father
you know an uncle etc so you hear all
you know these people were out there
seeing something unfold before them
where they couldn't help and when they
tried to help we heard from genevieve
hanson remember the
firefighter she tried to help she said
that i can come in
i i have certain skills of course she
could help help medically
and she was rebuffed and she was very
angry on the stand
so you had a lot of regret you had a lot
of anger you had a lot of fear
and people thinking all of them wanted
to help him and they think if only i
could have helped him he would have
lived
we also heard from donald williams the
the passerby who was quite vocal
in his evidence and he actually argued
with the officers
yes he argued with the officers he
and he admitted um using some names
um and every time the defense attorney
confronted him with a certain name that
he used he said yeah i said that
and then again he said yeah i said that
because he was very angry
and he was saying he can't breathe
he's not breathing you know he can't
breathe
and they were just ignoring him so he
just got more and more angry but you
know on the stand he wouldn't say that
he was angry
he basically said that he was just
trying to help
how has this been playing out in in the
state so
what's the the mood out there well it's
you know it's it's a huge case and it's
it's playing out in every city
we've had protests you know ever since
this happened it's been a year ago
as of may people are glued to
streaming footage of the trial
glued to tv coverage everybody's talking
about it
people have opinions about it you know
some people are saying
that you know he'll never get a fair
trial this officer but i think most
people are saying
we saw the video we all know what
happened
and it wasn't just eight minutes and 46
seconds now it was nine minutes and some
23 seconds or more and we even have
their own department
the minneapolis police department one of
the most senior ranking
lieutenants in the department saying
that this
this wasn't right and that when somebody
is prone and handcuffed and is not
resisting and in fact doesn't appear to
be moving
then that's not a time to use force
and bremen thank you very much for
sharing your legal expertise with us
thank you
the case continues
time now for a look at the weather
here's ness
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning so far this easter weekend
it has been
fine for many areas but we are going to
start seeing a change from the north
by the end of today as a cold front
sweeps its way
southwards across scotland and overnight
and tomorrow clearing but
northerly winds bringing through cold
arctic airflow
so it will be cold for everywhere on
easter monday with wintry hazards until
then
lots of sunshine out there this morning
but it's a chilly start frosty too with
some
isolated fog pack just less cold down
towards the south and east where it's
cloudy
and also across the north and west not
as cold as yesterday morning going into
this afternoon and the cloud will
actually uh peel back across
parts of eastern and southeastern
england where it has been rather cloudy
and cool recently so some warm and
bright spells there in fact lots of
sunshine for most of england wales and
island this afternoon
and dry weather too but somewhat
cloudier across scotland and later over
northern ireland the north of the
republic and northwest england
with rain spreading southwards there
then later wintry showers and strong
winds in the north
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
with us now to take us through the
newspapers broadcaster and journalist
sofia dom
and editor of challenges northern
ireland thomas copeland welcome back to
both of you
starting with the times front page
thomas you can look at this story
and this is the very worrying stat that
200 000 children will move from
primary to secondary schools without
being able to read properly because of
lack of time in school during the
pandemic that's right this is
unpublished government figures that have
been released to the sunday times this
morning
um a grand total 840 million school days
lost that's around 19 weeks per pupil
that's on average how much each student
at that age has lost in terms of
schooling this year
now the illiteracy figures is a rise of
30
000 leaving around 200 000 students
moving from secondary
sorry moving from primary into secondary
with uh
you know inhibitions in terms of uh
their ability to read
and write now i mean there's another
conversation really to have about the
why it is that 150 thousands under
normal circumstances are moving from
primary into secondary
it was with some level of illiteracy but
it's undoubted that the pandemic has
rapidly uh you know expanded the number
of students who are suffering in this
way
it's clear that you know this is a
fundamental period of your life that you
know the last couple of years of primary
in particular moving into secondary
and it would not surprise me at all if
that cohort of students from that age
group
unless there's fairly significant
support from the government intervention
over the next number of years
if that is a cohort that is recognizable
in the future
on account of the fact that they've lost
that very fundamental part of their
learning at a young age
so the times today is outlining some of
what the government's intending to do
things like they've appointed a catch-up
education star
talking about extending some of the
terms cutting away some of the holidays
yet another dad's army style uh surge in
order to try to recruit some
some retired teachers who i'm sure he'll
be thrilled to come back into the
teaching industry
um right now the thing that concerns me
i suppose is that this has got to be
more than just spellings and grammar so
much of what kids of that age are
missing out on
is that interaction with other students
it's about socializing it's about
messing about it's about
learning from each other that's
fundamental to the education process
and if this kind of education catch-up
program
is just focused on learning your
spellings learning your abc
reciting off your times tables then i
don't think that's going to adequately
catch up on the kind of experience that
these students have
lost out on over the last year yeah well
let's hope they will be able to sort of
claw it back
and and actually make up for the the
extra lessons and you can't make up for
the time missed with
your friends but you know hopefully
you'll be able to meet up in the future
let's move on to the
guardian uh and this story is about the
um
the race commission that the government
um
published this week it's had much
criticism but the guardian's actually
pointing to some other elements that are
a little known about the the actual
report
absolutely jillian so as you said this
was the report by the commission on race
and ethnic disparities that was
published this week
and like you said it's been very
controversial and widely criticized
and one of the recommendations that tony
sewell wanted to have
in the report that didn't make it so
this is something
that didn't go into the report and
hasn't come to fruition
is that he wanted to teach a new subject
in schools
and he wanted to teach children the
truth about modern britain
he also wanted to have a textbook
produced that would be
would have been rolled out to schools
and this was kind of based on a russian
model something that they've done in
russia to teach the history of russia
now this has hit a nerve because um
as we know this report has been widely
condemned by experts
in health in education and in race and
economics
and who have said that the report saying
that institutional racism
doesn't exist that that is fundamentally
wrong
and the concern would be that if there
had been a textbook printed then some of
the things that are written in the
report that have been widely disputed
would have made their way into that
textbook now like i said
this isn't a recommendation that came to
fruition
this textbook would not be reduced and
produced
sorry and actually the report includes a
clear recommendation for the department
of education to work with an independent
panel
to produce high quality teaching
resources
to tell the multiple and nuanced stories
of the contribution
of people from different different
ethnic minorities today
so the guardian have written quite a lot
about
the report that came out from the
commission of racial disparities
over the past week so another story for
them uh like i said
at tony so i wanted to have this new
subject to teach
modern day britain in schools but like i
said this is something that didn't
make it into the report and i think
people will be quite glad about that
um interesting the sun thomas uh this is
about the
the raid on a church by the the police
because they weren't practicing
social distancing rules
[Music]
that's right this is a story that went
viral online over the weekend
the video shows a good friday service
taking place in the south of london two
police officers walk right up to the
altar you can see a little bit of a
picture of it there
a turnaround until they assembled
congregation
uh they need to head home they aren't
abiding by the coronavirus
regulations now as you'd expect the
church say yes we were we had face masks
on we were two meters apart
the police say no you weren't there were
all sorts of regulations that you
weren't abiding by
a lot of anger you know has been
directed at the police over this over
the last couple of days which i think is
kind of
50 the wrong approach in this you know i
i feel at this stage
there's a huge amount of coronavirus
restriction fatigue
and the pretense that a lot of us had
that we fully understand the rules seem
to have dropped i mean
i i'm an above average consumer of news
i i watch sky news
and follow the fantastic coverage on
here and i would tell you that
i right now i couldn't accurately tell
you what all the rules and regulations
are whether it's the rule of six is it a
rule of ten
two people one garden the kind of mental
discipline that we had at the start of
this pandemic in terms of understanding
what the rules are
and how they apply seems to have
disappeared somewhat the problem i find
you know there's an incoherence ever so
slightly
bleeding into yes you can see an image
of it there leading into the law
uh and for that look to the politicians
i mean i've seen the
images of mps are protesting this new uh
police bill despite the fact that they
voted for the restrictions
that banned protests under the
coronavirus guidelines
so coming out of this pandemic i think
what we need to make sure is that we get
a better grip on on exactly how these
regulations work
make sure that we understand them fully
i think there's probably
a problem in parliament over the next
number of the last number of months of
just voting things through
yeah no yeah people definitely need to
to make sure they understand the rules
just very quickly uh staying with easter
theme
but we are running out of eggs there's
an easter egg shortage mafia this is the
guardian
yes this is from the guardian so you've
got people posting stories
and pictures on social media that they
aren't able to find easter eggs in shops
so of course we know we had shortages of
toilet roll and eggs
last easter and this year it is easter
egg so
some people going to 10 stores and still
not being able to find
their supply of easter eggs
an egg from either of you